Навіть після виходу на пенсію, німецькі президенти,
канцлери та міністри коштують платникам податків
чималих грошей.
Президенти Німеччини після завершення строку повноважень
отримують таку ж зарплатню, як і чинний глава держави -
нині це 236 тисяч євро на рік.
100-відсоткова зарплата не зберігається
у жодного іншого колишнього державного діяча -
ні в міністрів, ні в канцлерів.
Натепер у ФРН - три колишніх президенти -
Йоахім Ґаук, Крістіан Вульф та Горст Келер.
Окрім почесної зарплати вони мають право
на службову машину з шофером та офіс зі співробітниками.
І саме офіси - чи не найбільша стаття видатків.
За останніми даними Федеральної рахункової палати,
які оприлюднили німецькі ЗМІ,
залежно від президента на пенсії, за останні п’ять років
на офіси витрачено від 900 тисяч
до 2,3 мільйонів євро.
Приміром, площа офісу колишнього очільника ФРН,
імені якого не називають,
268 квадратних метрів,
його оренда коштує 89 000 євро на рік.
І це при тому, що офіси ці почесні пенсіонери
використовують в середньому менше трьох днів на місяць.
Як і президенти-пенсіонери, федеральні канцлери
після складення повноважень отримують виплати з бюджету,
а також офіси зі співробітниками.
Натепер єдиним колишнім канцлером Німеччини
є Ґергард Шредер.
Попри керівну посаду у російському нафтогазовому концерні "Роснефть",
він щомісяця отримує пенсію у 6 446 євро
- це третина зарплати чинної канцлерки Анґели Меркель.
А оренда берлінського офісу Шредера торік,
за повідомленнями німецького уряду,
коштувала бюджету 561 тисячу євро.
У Федеральній рахунковій палаті ставлять під сумнів
необхідність "пожиттєвого утримання" колишніх канцлерів.
Пенсія депутатів німецького Бундестагу
не може скаладати більше 67,5 процентів
від так званих "дієт". Нині чинні парламентарі
отримують близько  9 800 євро.
Однак для такої високої пенсії
обранці мають пропрацювати у парламенті 27 років.
Пенсії депутати отримують,
коли їм виповнюється 65 років.
Тим часом колишні міністри отримують пенсію,
якщо пропрацювали на цій посаді щонайменше два роки.
Якщо до чотирьох років - це третина від зарплати міністра,
при цьому на кожен додатковий рік
сума дещо збільшується - на майже два з половиною відсотки
Пенсія не може перевищити 72 відсотків.
Якщо ж міністр на пенсії іде в бізнес,
то розмір пенсії зменшиться рівно на розмір
його доходів від підприємницької діяльності.